prayer.
One of the things I
remembered when I was standing there was that
many of us tried to
chase after people based on how much money he had, how many houses he owned
in Sudan and Somalia. He was saving money
so he could get a bike to come to the mosque. His most important thing was attending the mosque, helping people, and making it easy for them. God Almighty would have taken him. His
last
words were, "There is no god but God, Muhammad is the Messenger of
God." Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him, was the
greatest difference from this world. God Almighty made
his command. God Almighty made
his command. God Almighty makes
all things possible.
Whoever intends the Hereafter,
God Almighty will gather his affairs and make him content. God Almighty makes all things possible.
God Almighty will gather his affairs and
make him content. God Almighty will make him content. God Almighty will make all things possible. We do
n't know how things are going to be. How can we
hope and make God take him?
God
Almighty is an Asian from all.  of the people only
them in the last 10 years and Allah and
he doesn't even have much family in this
country look how much
Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him, if Allah loves
his servant, Allah makes him one of his
last
deeds, deeds that Allah loves, and then makes him, and Allah, the Exalted, and then Allah, the Most High, grants him the
highest Paradise with the prophets,
the truthful, and the martyrs. And may
Allah bless our Prophet Muhammad and his family and all his companions.